[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es ein sizilianisches gericht
und zwar gibt es ab monat haben das ist
ein gemüse gericht mit auberginen und
tomaten das variiert von region zu
region und bei uns gibt's heute
gebackenen väter dazu und das ganze
konservieren entweder auf baguette oder
zum beispiel mit nudeln ich zeige ich am
ende einfach beides ihr seht hier schon
ich habe ganz viel gemüse legen das
heißt es ein super leckeres und vor
allem sehr frisches rezept und ich
stelle euch mal ganz kurz die zutaten
vorm fest abona brauche ich zwei
auberginen sind etwa 600 gramm einen
esslöffel salz hier habe ich olivenöl
400 gramm tomaten eine zwiebel 1
knoblauchzehe 2 stangen staudensellerie
ich habe ich zwei teelöffel kakaopulver
und einen halben teelöffel salz und
einen teelöffel zucker für den feta-käse
brauche ich 200 km2 rosmarinzweige etwas
pfeffer und salz natürlich hier habe ich
noch zwei esslöffel balsamico 60 gramm
entstand durch schwarze oliven 30 gramm
kapern und ein paar pinienkerne und zum
schluss brauche ich noch petersilie das
gemüse habe ich jetzt bereits
geschnitten die auberginen sind in 2 cm
große würfel geschnitten und da gebe ich
es den esslöffel salz drauf so kann ich
dir ein bisschen besser vor dem anbraten
und ich stelle jetzt für etwa 10 bis 15
minuten zur seite und kann jetzt hier
schon mal den väter vorbereiten
und zwar habe ich jetzt hier einen fass
gereift und väter da hat ein richtig
tolles aroma und jetzt auch wirklich
sehr intensiv im geschmack was wirklich
super lecker ist und hier sehr gut dazu
passt
jetzt gebe ich einfach ein bisschen
olivenöl in einer auflaufform
bestreichen dann den schafskäse rein
hier kommen jetzt die rosmarinzweige
drüber und auch ein bisschen pfeffer
wer möchte kann es hier noch thymian
darzulegen oder auch nicht in chili mit
rein geben und dann kommt das jetzt so
in den backofen und wird dann bei 200
grad etwa 15 bis 20 minuten gebacken
[Musik]
die auberginen werden nachdem entwässern
dann mit viel kaltem wasser ausgewaschen
damit das salz wieder weggewaschen wird
und dann müsst ihr sie wirklich
ordentlich ausdrücken damit die
komplette flüssigkeit wegkommt so sehen
sie jetzt aus hier habe ich jetzt
bereits sechs esslöffel olivenöl in
einem großen topf wie jetzt
jetzt gibt dir vorsichtig rein und
könnte dann fünf minuten anbraten und
die zeit können die jetzt übrigens auch
nutzen und die beilage schon vorbereiten
entweder könnt ihr jetzt zum beispiel
nudeln dazu servieren oder ihr könnt
paket aufschneiden und rösten und dann
das baguette damit anrichten oder nehmen
dieses gericht einfach als beilage zu
fleisch zum beispiel
jetzt nehme ich hier über schienen
wieder aus dem kopf heraus die stelle
ich kurz zur seite
jetzt kommt hier das restliche olivenöl
wieder in den topf gemeinsam mit der
zwiebel und die homepage ist damit ich
einfach schöne zwiebelringe habe
[Musik]
da kommen jetzt die knoblauch würfel mit
dazu und werden kurz mit den zwiebeln
angebraten
jetzt kommen hier die sellerie würfel
mit dazu und werden noch mal fünf
minuten mit angebraten
[Musik]
jetzt lasse ich das gemüse mit dem
balsamico und dann kommen jetzt auch die
restlichen zutaten mit rein also tomaten
dann auch die gewürze und cacau zu
kommen oliven und körper und auch der
rosmarinzweig und dann lasse ich das
jetzt mit decken bei niedriger stufe
etwas 10 minuten köcheln und gebe aber
nach fünf minuten die auberginen wieder
mit rein und dann haben wir es im
prinzip auch schon geschafft und ich
kann in der zwischenzeit nudeln abkochen
baguette ein bisschen resten die
pinienkerne reste ich hier auch in der
pfanne ohne fett und kann dann das
gericht noch mit salz und pfeffer
abschmecken und wir sind nicht fertig
[Musik]
so sieht das gericht jetzt aus sie habe
ich einmal mit nudeln serviert einmal
auf baguette auf fleisch kann stieß er
eigentlich denken heute gibt's
gefälligst okay also ich probier's mal
kann man damit auch mit anderen nudeln
machen und ja klar ich habe zwar falle
genommen mannschaft ja ich war ich bin
der sommer fallen
und hier noch der kampf geht dann habe
ich dann einfach genommen und sowieso
drüber gebrütet und das schafft das hat
echt genial oder braucht um 0 2 punkte
das ist erst mal sagen hause immer sagst
ja irgendwie süß sind hier auf dem
parkett hier nimmt und dann auf den käse
auf paket kann es auch gerne probieren
oder bist du mehr so nudel fern
ich glaube ich mit baguette und nun von
hier ist also ja es also soweit diese
noch den yamaha aus dem backofen ist für
mich auch so ein abend gericht wenn ich
mal ganz schnell was zu essen möchte was
leckere weil ich nicht überhaupt gewesen
fasst käse aus der schweiz da intensiv
im geschmack als er wirklich gut da mit
paar tomaten zwiebeln mit ryan ab im
backofen und schon habt ihr ein
perfektes abendessen wird ihr macht es
noch mit dem ablassen
und wie schmeckt ja eigentlich das abo
natel data converter die schuld bei
wirklich gut gelb mit den oliven und
ruth noch mal machen
sehr schön falls ihr auch interesse an
dem rezept arisch mit wahnsinniger gelb
dann schaut aufs ellis - blog.de vorbei
da steht noch mal alles ganz genau ich
bin auch ein großer fan von diesem
rezept probiert es einfach mal aus sagt
uns eure meinung und ich wünsche euch
einen guten appetit uns auch einen guten
appetit denn wir haben jetzt auch freier
abend und werden das jetzt zusammen
essen also bis zum nächsten mal
super ich weiß gar nicht dass das war
alles also auf einmal ich mache dir die
entscheidung leicht ich nenne das
züge auf der strecke
[Musik]